8 jrce créée par une loi de 2004 ces
juridictions au groupe des magistrats du
parquet et de l'instruction qui dispose
d'une compétence et d'une expérience
particulière en matière de lutte contre
la criminalité organisée et la
délinquance financière
leurs moyens techniques renforcer leur
permettent ainsi devenir un bien leurs
enquêtes notamment en matière de trafic
de stupéfiants et d'infractions commises
en bande organisée actuellement la gers
de fort de france est compétent pour les
antilles et la guyane
or outre que le territoire guyanais se
trouvent dans le bassin amazonien dont
les spécificités sont totalement
différentes de celles du bassin caribéen
la guyane est désormais confronté un
trafic exponentiel de stupéfiants en
provenance des pays voisins en
particulier du surinam avec une montée
de la délinquance et de la criminalité
liée à ce narcotrafic la création d'une
gers amazonienne en guyane apparaît de
plus en plus nécessaire celle ci aurait
pour mission de lutter sur le terrain et
à l'échelle transfrontalière contre le
trafic de stupéfiants qui détruit la
société guyanaise et dont les effets
s'exporte vers l'hexagone la guyane
étant devenue une des grandes portes
d'entrée de la cocaïne en euros une
telle structure permettrait d'être très
efficace sur le terrain car on
déploierait des moyens qui doivent être
proportionnelles aux défis
transfrontalier qui se posent à notre
état au niveau sud américain la
situation n'est plus la même qu'en 2004
et le rattachement de la guyane à la
gers de fort de france est désormais
totalement inadapté au regard des
mutations qui se sont opérés dans une
grande région amazonienne en termes de
trafic transfrontalier
le ministère de la justice s adapter en
fonction des évolutions
il l'a prouvé par exemple en recréant
une cour d'appel de plein exercice à
cayenne en janvier 2012
je souhaite donc connaître madame la
ministre vos intentions sur la
possibilité de création d'une jrce en
guyane ainsi que sur tous les moyens
judiciaires pouvant être mis en place
pour lutter contre les narcotrafics je
vous remercie
même le russe prend
sur le président madame la sénatrice
comme vous l'avez parfaitement rappeler
la guyane département frontalier du
brésil et du surinam est située sur le
ressort de la juridiction interrégionale
spécialisée de fort-de-france compétente
pour connaître d'affaires de criminalité
organisée et financière de grande
complexité tant sur les caraïbes que sur
la guyane
cette organisation se traduit par une
prise en charge effective de la
délinquance organisée guyanaise
notamment le narcotrafic dont vous
dénoncer à juste titre les ravages la
lutte contre ces trafics illégaux est
une priorité de la politique pénale du
ministère de la justice et le ministre
de la justice et s'excuse mais s'exprime
par ma voix et je partage vos légitimes
préoccupations très concrètement vous
avez raison le nombre d'affaires de
guyane suivi par cette juridiction de
fort de france a nettement augmenté
depuis 2004 le nombre total de dossiers
guyane est traitée ou en cours de
traitement par cette juridiction de fort
de france depuis 2004 s'élève au nombre
de 27 18 de criminalité organisée
neuf économique et financier soit 14 %
de son portefeuille les dossiers
guyanais en cours représente aujourd'hui
21% de l'ensemble du portefeuille de
cette juridiction
soit quinze dossiers 8 de criminalité
organisée et 7 économique et financier
le nombre de dossiers en provenance de
la guyane donnant lieu à la saisine de
la juridiction est passée en moyenne de
1,25 saisine entre 2004 et 2010 est à
une moyenne de 4,3 saisine sur la
période 2018 2020 cette évolution de la
délinquance apparaît toutefois à date
correctement prise en charge à ce stade
par la juridiction inter régionale
spécialisée de fort de france qui a su
s'adapter aux défis que connaît la
guyane en matière de criminalité
organisée
la guyane bénéficient d'une expertise
spécifique et des moyens renforcés
depuis 2010 9 de la juridiction de fort
de france
affectation supplémentaire d'un
magistrat du parquet juge d'instruction
et insistants spécialisé douaniers qui
définit sa politique pénale en prenant
précisément en compte les spécificités
de la criminalité organisée guyane
eze et en s'attachant à renforcer la
coopération internationale sur la zone
grâce notamment à l'appui de du
magistrat de liaison basée au brésil qui
est également compétent sur le surinam
enfin le périmètre de compétence d'une
juridiction inter-régionale spécialisée
par construction s'inscrit sur un espace
interrégionale est une création se
limitant au seul département de la
guyane serait contradictoire avec
l'objet même de cette organisation
judiciaire qui vise à mutualiser les
moyens en donnant une taille critique au
ressort de chaque juridiction afin d'en
améliorer l'efficacité
pour toutes ces raisons il n'est pas à
ce stade d'envisager de créer une telle
juridiction spécifique en guyane qui
risquerait d'amoindrir la juridiction
inter régionale spécialisée de fort de
france qui opère sur la guyane et les
antilles françaises
mais vous le savez le ministère de la
justice reste très vigilant à ce que
toutes les évolutions de la délinquance
soient prises en compte celle qui a un
prix créé une adaptation de son
organisation judiciaire dans les
territoires en outre mer comme en
métropole
je vous remercie oui merci pour votre
réponse je mange estime qu' il faut
qu'une réflexion soit menée parce que
nous sommes pas sur le même continent
et je dis que nous gainey quand
allons-nous obtenir une indépendance en
tout cas une certaine autonomie de notre
situation de narcotrafic
merci